existen varios tipos de vídeos de khan
academy que explican qué es la anotación
científica y dan algunos ejemplos lo que
quiero hacer en este vídeo es usar el
libro de álgebra seca 12.8 para hacer
más ejemplos de notación científica
tomemos algunas cosas que están escritas
en notación científica y recordemos que
la notación científica es útil debido a
que nos permite escribir cantidades muy
grandes o muy pequeñas de manera que le
es más fácil a nuestros cerebros
escribir y comprender escribamos algunos
números tengo 3.102 por 10 a la segunda
potencia y quiere escribirlo como valor
numérico este ya está escrito en
notación científica pues está escrito
como un producto con una potencia de 10
así que como voy a escribir esto
hay una manera rápida y una lenta la
manera lenta es como sigue esto lo voy a
escribir como 3.102 por cien que es el
10 elevado al cuadrado
me va a quedar
310 200 y voy a colocar el punto decimal
tres lugares atrás de donde debería
estar lo voy a poner aquí 300 10.200 que
es la respuesta correcta 310 punto 2
una manera más rápida de hacer esto es
tengo el 3 adelante del punto decimal y
si lo tengo multiplicado por 10 a la
segunda potencia simplemente voy a mover
el punto decimal dos lugares a la
derecha 1 2 pues es 10 elevado a la
segunda potencia quedando 310 punto 2
esto es más fácil de hacer ya que cada
que multiplicó por 10 el punto decimal
se recorre un lugar a la derecha
hagamos otro ejemplo digamos que tengo
7.4 por 10 a la cuarta potencia
hagámoslo de la manera rápida movamos el
punto decimal cuatro lugares a la
derecha tenemos 7.4 lo movemos un lugar
porque si es a la 1 ahora 10 al cuadrado
va a ser moverlo otro lugar agregamos un
0 para poder hacer este movimiento del
punto decimal 10 a la 3 es 7.400 y
multiplicado a la cuarta que nos queda
74 mil como ven recogió el punto 4
lugares así que esto es igual a 74 mil
74 mil
cuando tenía el 74 tuve que agregar un
cero porque estoy multiplicando por 10
otra manera de ver esto es que necesito
4 lugares entre el dígito principal y el
punto decimal y aquí van a estar los
espacios 1 2 3 4
hagamos más ejemplos para comprenderlo
mejor aquí voy a tener un 1.75 por 10 a
la menos 3 esto esta anotación
científica y quiero escribir el valor
numérico de esto cuando tenemos algo
multiplicado por 10 elevado a una
potencia negativa se va a recorrer el
punto decimal hacia la izquierda
tengo 1.75 si lo multiplicamos por 10 a
la menos 1 recorremos el punto decimal
un lugar hacia la izquierda si es 10 a
la menos 2 recorremos el punto 2 lugares
a la izquierda y agregamos un 0 para
poder recorrer el punto si tenemos 10 a
la menos 3 agregó otro 0 recorro el
punto decimal a la izquierda haremos un
0 y nos queda que la respuesta es 0.00
175 que es lo mismo que 1.75 por 10 a la
menos 3 otra forma de revisar que se
tiene la respuesta correcta es si
tenemos el 1 aquí contando al 1
incluyendo los ceros a la derecha del
punto decimal se debe tener el mismo
número que el exponente negativo aquí
así que tenemos 123 números detrás del
punto decimal que es lo mismo que la
potencia menos 3 que tenemos aquí esto
es una milésima hagamos otro ejemplo y
ahora comencemos con algo que está
escrito como numeral y después lo vamos
a escribir usando la notación científica
digamos que tengo 120.000 como valor
numérico y quiero escribirlo en notación
científica voy a tomar el dígito
principal
1.2 x 10 elevado a la y ahora solo
cuento cuántos dígitos están detrás del
dígito principal 1 2 3 4 5 así que tengo
1.2 x 10 a las 5 si quieren comprender
mejor porque esto tiene sentido 10 al 5
es 100.000 por lo que 1.2 por 100.000
si en mí tenemos cinco ceros que es 10 a
las 5 esta multiplicación va a ser
120.000 espero que esto les ayude a
comprenderlo mejor hagamos otro ejemplo
el valor numérico es un millón
setecientos sesenta y cinco mil 244 y
quiero escribir esto en notación
científica toma el dígito principal que
es 1 le pongo el punto decimal y todo lo
demás va después de este punto decimal 7
6 5 2 4 4
y luego contamos cuántos dígitos hay
entre el principal y el punto decimal
porque es posible que tengan números
después del punto decimal así que entre
el dígito principal y el signo del punto
decimal y tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 dígitos
esto es por 10 a la 6 y esto es un
millón lo cual tiene sentido pues 1.7
aproximadamente multiplicado por un
millón
va a ser aproximadamente 1.7 millones
esto es un poco más de un millón 700 por
lo que tiene perfecto sentido hagamos
otro ejemplo como escribo 12 en notación
científica por lo que va a ser igual a
1.2 por contamos los dígitos que entre
el 1 y el punto decimal que nada más hay
un dígito y es 10 a la primera potencia
lo que definitivamente va a ser igual a
hagamos un par de ejemplos más pero
ahora con potencias negativas
tengo 0.00 281 y queremos escribir la
anotación científica tenemos que pensar
en cuántos dígitos hay después del punto
decimal para llegar a la cifra
significativa contemos van a ver
incluyendo nuestra cifra significativa
van a ver 123 lugares por lo que tenemos
que mover nuestro punto decimal 1 2 3
lugares hacia la derecha
una forma de pensar en ello es
multiplicando esto por 10
a la 3 pero esto cambiaría su valor así
que también tendríamos que multiplicarlo
por 10 a la menos 3 para que quede igual
sería como multiplicarlo por uno no
cambia su valor esta parte a que sería
igual
esta parte esto que estoy subrayando
bueno nuevo el punto decimal tres
lugares a la derecha y queda 2.81 y
ahora la cifra nos quedaría por 10 a la
menos 3 otra manera más rápida de
hacerlo es contar los espacios entre el
punto decimal y el dígito principal son
3 así que nos queda 2.81 por 10 a la
menos 3 hagamos otro ejemplo subimos la
pantalla y digamos que tengo 0.01 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 0 y luego escribo 1 2
7 ahora contamos todos los dígitos
detrás del punto decimal hasta el 2
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 y 8 así que será 2.7 por
10 a la menos 8 ahora hagamos otro
problema donde comenzamos con el valor
en notación científica y queremos llegar
al valor numérico simplemente para
mezclar las cosas 2.9 por 10 a la menos
5 una manera es recorrer el punto
decimal hacia la izquierda por lo que
tendríamos 4 ceros más tendríamos
entonces 29 y 40 hacia la izquierda 1 2
3 4 ceros y aquí podríamos nuestro punto
decimal supe que se necesitaban 40 es
porque conté 1 2 3 4 5 los espacios a
recorrer del punto hacia la izquierda
incluyendo el dígito principal así que
queda 0.00 0 029
ahora para verificar tenemos otra
técnica como escribo esta anotación
científica voy a contar todos los ceros
principales a la derecha del punto
incluyendo el primer número diferente a
cero así que tengo 1 2 3 4 5 dígitos así
que será 10 a la menos 5 tendremos 2.9
por 10 a la menos 5
y nuevamente aquí no hay nada de magia
esto tiene mucho sentido si yo quisiera
tener este número como 2.9 por 10 a la
menos 5 tendría que tener recorrer el
punto 1 2 3 4 5 lugares
si multiplico puntos 0 0 0 0 29 por 10 a
la 5 lo tendré que multiplicar por 10 a
la menos 5 así no he cambiado el número
ya que esto es como multiplicar por 1
esta parte
eso sería igual a 11 y puedo escribir
esta parte de aquí que si hago la
multiplicación va a quedar el punto
decimal recorrido 5 lugares quedando 2.9
por 10 a la menos 5
espero que esto les haya aclarado lo que
es la notación científica